35 degrés sur le thermomètre 27 dans
l'eau le choix d'aller se rafraîchir à
la piscine apparaît comme une évidence
beaucoup de personnes avec les fortes
chaleurs voilà on est venu s'infléchir
avec les enfants avec les amis voilà la
piscine de saint germain se rafraîchir
ou s'il fait chaud et puis computer a dû
11 je mange il me baignais cam épouse on
est venu accompagner les enfants comme
il faisait chaud donc
en a profité lors des épisodes
caniculaires c'est toujours le même
constat les entrées explose avec ses
trois bassins dont un extérieur et un de
50 mètres et son solarium de deux
hectares la piscine intercommunale le
dôme de saint germain en laye n'est pas
en reste on a globalement des pics
notamment sur les jours où les
températures sont beaucoup plus haute en
été majoritairement ce sont des familles
qui viennent à la piscine mais aussi des
adolescents qui viennent s'amuser
lorsqu'ils peuvent pas venir partir en
vacances ce côté détente que la piscine
va pouvoir leur apporter avec les fortes
températures ce côté bronzette qu'ils
vont pouvoir avoir sur le solarium et on
a un petit snack qui leur permet de
pouvoir se restaurer manger une petite
glace lors des pics de fréquentation des
mesures sont prises dans l'établissement
pour maximiser la surveillance et
optimiser l'espace c'est plus compliqué
derrière on rajoute nous un stade
supplémentaire à la fois sur la sécurité
mais aussi sur les maîtres nageurs de
manière à assurer une sécurité pour nos
visages et qu'on a mis en place à
l'accueil dé fil dédiés aux différents
publics n'a mis en place aussi pour le
bassin pour nos publics nageurs un
espace dédié pour eux avec des lignes de
nage dans le grand bassin mais également
dans le bassin extérieur le dôme de
saint germain en laye est ouvert du
lundi au dimanche de 11h à 20h jusqu'au
31 août la vague de chaleur devrait
quant à elle s'estomper rapidement dans
les jours à venir dans les yvelines